من الصعب عدم المجادلة بأن كوفاكس
لم يرق إلى مستوى التوقعات
التي توقعها الكثيرون في وقت مبكر من هذا
الوباء ، وهناك تباين كبير
بين أولئك في العالم الذين
يتجادلون الآن حول ما إذا كان ينبغي أن يحصلوا على
جرعة ثالثة وأولئك الذين
لم نتمكن من الوصول إلى أحد ، كيف وصلنا إلى
هنا دكتور لوترباخ وما الذي
كان يمكن فعله لمنع هذا ،
وأعتقد أن الأهم من ذلك ما يمكن فعله
للتأكد من أننا نلحق بهذه
المساواة التفاوت بين أولئك
الذين لديهم  الوصول
أعتقد أن
الاتحاد الأوروبي
قد ارتكب خطأ فادحًا
منذ حوالي عام عندما لم يكن
هناك استثمار كافٍ في
إنشاء قدرة
إنتاج للقاحات ، استثمرنا أساسًا فقط
في الطاقة الإنتاجية
التي كانت مطلوبة لتغطية أوروبا ،
ولم نفعل الكثير.  كان هذا في رأيي
خطأ فادحًا وقد قلت ذلك منذ عام
مضى وقبل ذلك ، وهذا هو المكان الذي
نتواجد فيه حاليًا ، وأعتقد أن ما يمكننا فعله حاليًا
هو أننا نحتاج إلى العمل بشكل أساسي
معًا أه أنا نفسي
أيضًا أعتقد أننا يجب أن نجعل
براءة الاختراع
متاحة للبلدان الفقيرة وهذا موقف
لا تشاركه
أنجيلا ميركل التي أتفق معها في العديد من
القضايا وأنا حقًا أه العمل
معها هو حقًا
ناجح ويسعدني ولكن  هنا
لدينا خلاف ،
أعتقد أنه لنفترض أن الأنماط
تجعل إتاحة الأنماط
للدول الفقيرة حتى تتمكن من
إنتاج اللقاحات
بأنفسهم ، ولا سيما تلك اللقاحات
التي يسهل إنتاجها إلى حد ما ،
فأنا أتفق مع بايدن
والإدارة أكثر من  مع
إدارتي ، نعم ، من المثير
للاهتمام والمحير أن نرى أن هذا
الخلاف هناك بين الحلفاء بشكل صحيح
وأولئك الذين يركزون بشكل خاص
على العلوم ،
أوضح لي الدكتور الرائع كيف يمكنك من
ناحية تقديم الحجة القائلة بأنه إذا لم نفعل ذلك
الحصول على لقاحات كافية لأولئك الذين لم يحصلوا على لقاح
بعد سنرى المزيد
والمزيد من المتغيرات
وقد تكون أقوى من
دلتا ولكن في  من ناحية أخرى ، عندما
يسمع شخص ما أن تلك الشركات
تنصح بإعطاء جرعات معززة ثالثة ،
فلديهم كل الحق في القول إنني أريد واحدة ،
لذا فأين تقف هنا ،
ما يجب أن نفعله هو اختيار 50
إلى 100 دولة
حول
العالم لديها  بعض القدرات الوليدة أو الجيدة لتصنيع اللقاحات
، ويجب أن نقوم بتصدير
مصانع اللقاحات ،
كان لدينا ذلك في حالة الجدري في شلل الأطفال ، كان لدينا
تصنيع إقليمي للقاحات ،
يجب أن نفهم أنه بمجرد حصولنا على
اللقاح ، لن تنتهي اللعبة ، فهذه
مجرد البداية.  للحصول
على اللقاح في آخر بوصة من
200 دولة ،
إنها مهمة هائلة
تتم بشكل أفضل إذا تم تصنيع اللقاح
محليًا وأنا على دراية بجميع
المشاكل
في مراقبة الجودة ولكن يمكن
إصلاحها
والشركات التي لديها براءات الاختراع  يمكنهم
بالفعل المطالبة بإتاوة
دعهم يكسبون المال. لا يهمني
تصدير
مصانع اللقاحات
وقدراتها لأنه لا يوجد مصنع واحد
سيكون قادرًا على ملء  لقد فاتورة
عشرات المليارات من جرعات اللقاح التي
سنحتاجها على مدى السنوات الثلاث المقبلة ،
ولم أرغب في تجاهل سؤالك
إذا لم يكن لدينا
لقاح في العالم النامي
في العالم الذي لا يحتوي على
لقاح
نحن  ستستمر في الجري عبر
الأبجدية اليونانية وربما تضطر إلى طلب
إضافة أبجدية مختلفة بعد ذلك مع
تباين لأنه لا يوجد ما يمنع
هذا الفيروس من تكرار
تحوير المتغيرات ما لم يصطدم بجدار
من الأشخاص الملقحين ويتم إزالة كثافة
المعرضين للإصابة
.  عدم القيام بذلك
بشكل كافٍ ولهذا السبب
لدينا هذا الدش من التباين